rajesh and atul gupta fled south africa
in 2018 after being charged with fraud
corruption and money laundering
although an interpol red notice has led
to the arrest of the brothers in dubai
it may be some time before they're
extradited presumably these these
suspects will be brought before a court
and they will then
utilize their rights to
try to resist the extradition
but if
if their petition to uh stop the
extradition is not successful then we
would expect to see that uh
that request ratified uh by the relevant
authorities and then for them to be
physically put on a plane and brought
back to south africa but it could it
could take some time
the guptas immigrated from india to
south africa in the early 1990s
their relationship with former president
jacob zuma is at the center of the
scandal surrounding the family zuma was
forced to resign in 2018 following
pressure from within his party it's
alleged the guptas influenced government
policy and the appointment of cabinet
ministers and looted state funds
an estimated 32 billion dollars was
stolen during zuma's nine years in
office
the former president is facing a
separate trial on charges of fraud
linked to a multi-million dollar arms
deal other gupta family members and
associates are currently on trial for
allegedly siphoning off state funds
meant for a farming project the gupta
brothers are also implicated many south
africans have welcomed the arrest but
political commentators say allegations
of corruption at the highest levels of
government may not be limited to the
zuma administration current president
sul ramaphosa is facing his own scandal
he's accused of failing to report the
2020 theft of up to four million dollars
from his farm in the limpopo province
family al jazeera johannesburg